ми прискорили практично всі позиції
досягли першого консенсусу до Польщі
чарку ми знаходилися а так вже перед
викладкам я взяв і хитайся в полі
конституції та довгого законодавства і я
до проціону він і батіг йдуть двозначного
трактування рибних положень ким можемо
наприклад залиже і вигляд того якими будуть
чи політичні ти чого не на прихід
е налагодження патріотично краще не
так-то і шламу питання точно не
та деталізацію формулі вань аджики
формулювання ки сьогодні є
законопроекті закону про вид з нас
правді формулювання конституції
україни ми лаялися а логіку youth що
ці положення потрібно
у точні ти і деталізовані дарма що ю
так і поняття як your you ready зація
покладено конституції і з травня будуть і
зроблено у законі
тому поправках тусувалася fpr шутер ву
рослого дня замість конкретних положень це
була така логіка в принципі роботи
робочі групи колими уточню вали
як самі мої реалізовувалися а то че ін
ша норма та тему про свічки але владно
послуги
поправки